it's a hot day and you've just down
several glasses of water one after the
other
behind the sudden urge that follows our
to being shaped organs that work as
fine-tuned internal sensors they balance
the amount of fluid in your body detect
waste in your blood
and know when to release the vitamins
minerals and hormones you need to stay
alive say hello to your kidneys the main
role of these organs is to dispose of
waste products and to turn them into
urine the body's eight liters of blood
pass through the kidneys between 20 and
25 times each day
meaning that together these organs
filter about 180 liters every 24 hours
the ingredients in your blood are
constantly changing as you ingest food
and drink which explains why the kidneys
need to be on permanent duty blood
enters each kidney through arteries that
branch and branch until they form tiny
vessels that entwined with special
internal modules called nephrons in each
kidney 1 million of these nephrons form
a powerful array of filters and sensors
that carefully sift through the blood
this is where we see just how refined
and accurate this internal sensing
system is to filter the blood each
nephron uses two powerful pieces of
equipment a blob-like structure called a
glomerulus and a long stringy straw like
tube you'll the glomerulus works like a
sieve allowing only certain ingredients
such as vitamins and minerals to pass
into the tube you'll then this vessels
job is to detect whether any of those
ingredients are needed in the body if so
they're reabsorbed and amounts that the
body needs so they can circulate in the
blood again but the blood doesn't only
carry useful ingredients it contains
waste products too and the nephrons have
to figure out what to do with them the
tubules sense compounds the body doesn't
need like urea left over from the
breakdown of proteins and redirects them
as urine out of the kidneys and through
two long sewers called ureters these
tubes empty their contents into the
bladder to be discharged ridding your
body of that waste once and for all
there's water in that urine too if the
kidney detects too much of it in your
blood
for instance when you've chugged several
glasses at once it sends the extra
liquid to the bladder to be removed on
the other hand low water levels in the
blood prompt the kidney to release some
back into the bloodstream meaning that
less water makes it into the urine this
is why urine appears yellower when
you're less hydrated by controlling
water your kidneys stabilize the body's
fluid levels but this fine balancing act
isn't the kidneys only skill these
organs have the power to activate
vitamin D to secrete a hormone called
renin that raises blood pressure and
another hormone called erythropoietin
which increases red blood cell
production without the kidneys our
bodily fluids would spiral out of
control every time we eat our blood
would receive another load of unsifted
ingredients soon the build-up of waste
would overload our systems and we'd
expired so each kidney not only keeps
things running smoothly it also keeps us
alive lucky then that we have two of
these magical beans
you